[Musique]
bonsoir jeudi 1er juillet le journal de
tv soixante dix huit pour faire le tour
de l'actualité locale bienvenue si vous
nous rejoignez voici les titres double
déplacement ministériel ce jeudi dans
les yvelines jean castex était à
jambville le premier ministre a assisté
à la dernière journée de séjour des
jeunes engagés dans le service national
universel et dans le même temps jean
baptiste djebbari est élu à magny les
hameaux et visite sous fonds
d'innovation en matière de routes et de
mobilité pour le ministre délégué aux
transports après le second tour des
élections départementales séance
d'installation ce matin à versailles
pour la nouvelle assemblée pierre bédier
a été reconduit pour un nouveau mandat à
la tête de la collectivité et 12
vice-présidents été désigné avec
quelques nouveaux visages le détail à
suivre et puis nous vous emmenons en
balade à vélo à la fin de cette édition
au gré de pistes balisées l'avait
losséni permet de relier l'île de france
au mont saint michel
un itinéraire de 450 kilomètres nous en
avons parcouru une partie en vallée de
chevreuse invités de cette édition yves
lalonde champ nouveau président du coc
d'esquisser le conseil de développement
de saint quentin en yvelines
et puis à suivre le portrait de l'ina 14
ans atteinte de trisomie 21
elle nous la suivrons dans son parcours
scolaire une bataille de tous les
instants pour réussir son projet
professionnel
[Musique]
mais jean castex était donc ce jeudi 1er
juillet à jambville dans le nord des
yvelines le premier ministre et sarah et
léry secrétaire d'état chargée de la
jeunesse et de l'engagement ont
rencontré pendant deux heures 180 jeunes
âgés de 15 à 17 ans tous ont participé
volontairement un séjour de 12 jours
dans le cadre du service national
universel cette promesse de campagne
d'emmanuel mâcon remontant à 2017 et
lancé en 2019 a pour but de remplacer
indirectement le service militaire en
impliquant la genèse dans la vie de la
nation le sc nu elle devrait concerner à
terme 400 mille jeunes par an en france
on écoute les participants présents sur
place au micro de michael et demi
d'euros moi je me suis engagé parce que
je voulais savoir c'est quoi le sens de
l'engagement et j'ai vu c'était quoi le
son sur la gauche mais j'ai vu sa valeur
en même temps découvrir ce cadre
militaire un peu de groupes parce qu'on
vit quand même sous des tentes
et sansan ce qu'on veut dire sans cet
esprit de de cohésion est con on est un
peu tous dans le même bateau
jamais on n'aurait créer de lien aussi
fort aujourd'hui c'était c'était
intéressant on a appris plein de choses
s'étaient pas de comment kourou et un
professeur qui fait le cours et nous on
écrit c'était vraiment basé sur les
changes
et donc c'était beaucoup plus
intéressant que vraiment juste en salle
de classe
dans le même temps ce matin jean
baptiste djebbari celui rendu à magny
les hameaux le ministre délégué en
charge des transports était au groupe
colas le campus scientifique et
technique de l'entreprise participe au
développement des infrastructures
routières les précisions de nicolas
landry ce sont les routes du futur
intelligente connecter avec une
performance énergétique efficiente des
infrastructures développées ici au
campus scientifique et technique de
colas à magny les hameaux
une centaine de collaborateurs engagés
sur trois sujets la transition
environnementale la transformation
énergétique et numérique
c'est le cas de ce passage piéton
autonome en expérimentation à mandelieu
la napoule nantes ou encore dans le 15e
arrondissement de paris ce passage
piéton représenté par les bandes
blanches et lumineux une capacité en
fait à pouvoir s'illuminer au moment du
passage d'un piéton qui détecte et de
manière automatique par une caméra
thermique
la deuxième techno qui est combinée dont
qui sont les surfaces noires sont en
fait des cellules photovoltaïques ce qui
permet donc de capter l'énergie solaire
de la transformer en énergie électrique
et donc d'alimenter les bandes blanches
en led
en déplacement à magny les hameaux le
ministre délégué des transports jean
baptiste djebbari a pu découvrir
l'ensemble des innovations développées
par colas aujourd'hui était une bonne
étape pour s'apercevoir à la fois de
l'état de l'art sur le plan du
développement technologique et puis de
l'effort qui nous restent collectivement
à faire avec les collectivités les
acteurs privés les organismes de
recherche parce que c'était fera avec
l'état il est évidemment partenariat les
collectifs
la présence du ministre l'occasion pour
les professionnels des infrastructures
routières de rendre plusieurs
propositions pour améliorer le
déploiement des innovations c'est
simplifier et rendre accessible à un
maximum de collectivités on sait bien
qu'aujourd'hui sur le terrain est bien
souvent tellement hors de plus petites
communes aussi assez souvent
s'il n'a pas la compétence intrinsèque
dans son administration
eh bien il n'est pas toujours au fait de
ce qui peut faire comment le faire
comment le financer la poursuite du
développement des innovations dans ce
secteur
un travail collectif entre l'état les
collectivités les grands groupes et les
start up dans l'actualité également
l'installation du nouveau conseil
départemental des yvelines ce jeudi
matin les 42 conseillers élus dimanche
dernier lors des élections
départementales se sont rassemblés pour
désigner président vice président et
conseiller délégué une assemblée
entièrement dévolue au groupe ensemble
pour les yvelines qui a remporté l âme à
la majorité des cantons a c'est à dire
21 cantons ensemble pour les unes c'est
bien sûr la majorité de droite et du
centre au département mélanie poké c'est
le dernier pierre bédier
sans surprise pierre bédier garde son
fauteuil de président réélu avec 100%
des voix du conseil dans son discours
l'élu du canton de mantes-la-jolie a mis
en avant un département qui protège
c'est notre compétence première dans la
compétence sociale et en particulier le
rsa à la fois la distribution du rs 1
c'est donc le département qui financent
et qui finance au grand dam de ses
propres finances puisque l'état qui
devrait en théorie nous rembourser en
totalité ne le fait que aux deux tiers
autres quarts et nous avons aussi à côté
du rsa la politique d'insertion 12
vice-présidents ont aussi été élus lors
de cette séance pierrefonds reste
premier vice président marie hélène
aubert catherine arnould ou encore
joséphine coleman bergers sont aussi
présentes
la mère de plaisir avec nicolas
dainville sont les seuls représentants
de saint quentin en yvelines
six ans ça passe très vite on a
énormément travaillé avec mes collègues
dans tous les secteurs et on a toujours
la sensation qu'il ya des dossiers qui
sont en cours qu'il faut terminer donc
je remercie le président de sa confiance
et de cette vice-présidence que je vais
porter vraiment avec énergie des
nouveaux élus et nouveau vice président
âgé de seulement 26 ans geoffroy backs
de keating et élus 11e richarde le
pierre maire modem du chéné rocancourt
est 5e c'est évidemment un grand honneur
mais c'est voilà après si on est on
je suis très satisfait ça va ça va être
un engagement c'est vraiment derrière
beaucoup d'actions qui vont être
engagées au sein du département donc
j'arrive directement par la grande porte
et donc très satisfait et
après il ya peu d'appréhension
évidemment c'est la finalisation d'un
accord politique
le président avait souhaité élargir sa
majorité départementale le modem à voile
a signé un accord avec avec le président
et les résultats du scrutin nous ayons
été favorable le président a tenu ses
engagements et je l'en remercie
si les délégations seront officiellement
attribués lors de la prochaine séance du
conseil départemental celle de la santé
devrait être attribué à laurent richard
richarde le pierre obtiendrait les
mobilités geoffroy backs de keating
serait aux affaires sociales
nicole bristol aurez en charge
l'environnement autre assemblée installé
depuis quelques jours déjà celle du
codis qui le conseil de développement de
saint quentin en yvelines l'instance de
démocratie participative composé de
membres bénévoles est reparti pour un
mandat de trois ans avec un nouveau
président il est avec nous par
visioconférence yves long de chambon
soir bonsoir
président donc du code skis jeudi
nouveau président ce que vous succéder à
guy foucher qui est à la tête du conseil
depuis 2016 mais vous avez déjà par le
passé occupé cette fonction
avant de parler de cette nouvelle
assemblée qui a été installé rappelons
ce qu'est le codé ce qui en quelque
sorte une assemblée consultative des qui
est composé de citoyen saint quentinois
quelles sont ses missions au code skis
alors ministre et de l'accompagner afin
de nourrir la réflexion des élus avec
une réflexion citoyenne
plus précisément une réflexion de
citoyens et d'acteurs du territoire
d'acteurs économiques sociaux d'acteurs
de associatif
voilà et de simples citoyens qui sont
qui sont qu'ils ont été volontaires pour
participer aux côtés ce qui à l'issue
d'un appel à candidatures qui ont été
sélectionnés pour avoir avoir une
assemblée de citoyens représentative en
matière d'âge évidemment parité raul
femmes et puis une représentativité
aussi au niveau des territoires au
niveau des communes de saint quentin en
yvelines
voilà bénévoles ils sont répartis en 4
collèges c'est bien ça voilà tout à fait
donc il ya un collège dit vie
associative vie associative un collage
vie économique et sociale dissociatifs
et et démocratique
un collège dit vie économique d un
collège citoyens et puis un collège de
personnes qualifiées donc des personnes
qui ont une bonne connaissance du
territoire et une envie de s'investir il
ne rentre pas dans les trois catégories
précédentes et vous le disiez l'objectif
c'est de nourrir la réflexion des élus
de saint quentin en yvelines qui eux
vont décider les politiques à mener
alors il ya des exemples concrets qu'on
peut donner de travaux récents de la
part du codis qui est notamment un
travail assez gros qui a été réalisé sur
la jeunesse être jeune à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines c'était l'un
des axes de travail par le codis qui ces
dernières années
ce travail est issu des runes tout d'une
constatation que nous avons fait
en analysant les besoins en matière
d'habitat dans le cadre du plan du
programme local de l'habitat
nous avons constaté que les jeunes donc
été moins nombre de mois dans un endroit
parfait en yvelines lors que nous avons
cherché à savoir pourquoi ils nous avons
sondé sur trois thématiques l'habitat
précisément les déplacements et puis la
qualité de vie dans son ensemble et nous
avons partagé les résultats de cette
enquête avec les élus dont une rencontre
et lucau des skis qui ait lieu en fin
d'année n'ont pas dernière mais celle
d'avant avec fin 2019 voilà un exemple
de de travaux ne se contente pas d'être
un organe de réflexion est en fait
effectivement de désactiver des actions
concrètes pour pour alimenter notre
réflexion vous disais cette dernière
rencontre et du code s qui a eu lieu fin
2010 9 est ce que du coup la crise
sanitaire en quelque sorte on va dire
impacté les activités du code et ce qui
le fait de pouvoir se réunir de pouvoir
travailler ou finalement ces derniers
mois ça s'est pas ressenti vous vous
êtes adaptées aussi face à cette crise
sanitaire
un peu les deux parce qu'en fait que le
codesria avait terminé son mandat au
mois deux ans au mois de mars donc aux
mains de martin ont produit en fait un
début de crise sanitaire
simplement on a rassuré sur la vitesse à
pied d un certain nombre de groupes qui
ont continué à fonctionner notamment le
groupe plan climat sur le sur le climat
l'air énergie territorial pas ce qu'on
appelle le couple le plan climat air
énergie territorial de saint quentin en
yvelines
donc nous avons poursuivi les travaux de
ce groupe et nous avons effectivement
converti en cirant nos travaux en mode
de vie
conférence nous avons participé
notamment un projet de la coordination
nationale des conseils développement
entre du territoire donc saint quentin
en yvelines le la communauté urbaine de
dj ps et au donc de nord des yvelines et
puis un certain nombre de pensionnés
développement dans les régions et donc
nous avons échangé aussi etc séquencier
développement sur cette même thématique
de comment accélérer la l'appropriation
des enjeux théoriques des enjeux des
changements climatiques par des citoyens
les acteurs la nouvelle nouvelle
assemblée est installé je le disais pour
pour trois ans le mandat trois ans vous
êtes du coup le nouveau président pour
ce mandat de trois ans il y avait 96
membres il me semble dans la précédente
mandature
combien de membres cette fois ci pour le
codé ce qui est ce qu'il ya eu un
renouvellement du coût des personnes
présentes dans ce qu des skis il ya eu
un renouvellement très profond on est à
peu près 75 % de nouveaux membres
le nombre de membres fait environ 80
enfin 80 ou 100 selon que l'on compte
les fleuves les membres titulaires ou
également les membres suppléants parce
que les acteurs du territoire notamment
les acteurs économiques sont invités à
désigner un binôme de membres membres
titulaires et mon suppléant
donc on est en plus 80 il change dans la
façon dont on compte est bon coup double
est à peu près au coût de renouvellement
et y avait un appel à candidatures
d'ailleurs qui avait été lancé en début
d'année un pour avoir de nouveaux
membres au sein du coc des skis hees
avait eu un franc succès une dernière
question et blanc de chant quelle est la
suite des événements à présent est ce
qu'il ya déjà des axes de travail qui
ont été établies ou justement ça va être
l'objet des prochaines rencontres des
prochaines réunions pour le coc des skis
établir justement les axes de travail
pour les pour les prochaines années
la deuxième option c'est effectivement
nous allons établir les axes de travail
à la rentrée nous avons eu hier une
présentation des compétences de
l'agglomération et des principaux
projets par le directeur général des
services arrivent et makoun
ça fait partie du mode de travail du
connaissent rien d'avoir accès
formation de la part des à la fois des
élus et des services techniques de
l'agglomération la formation nécessaire
pour présentes puissent avoir une
réflexion pertinente
voilà donc le directeur général des
services nous a fait l'honneur et le
plaisir de nous présenter un panorama
global
à partir de là dont on ouvre à la
rentrée nous aurons une nouvelle
assemblée plénière pour définir les
aspirations des membres en matière de
deux sujets de nous organiser
peut-être de nommer un bureau et dans
l'intervalle nous avons nous allons
proposer à nos membres de de s'informer
nous mettons à leur disposition un outil
de collaboratif pour échanger et puis à
l'ensemble d'informations sûres sur les
projets de l'agglomération et sur les
réflexions passer du code skis de
manière à ce qu'ils puissent s'informer
pendant pendant les vacances et revenir
à la rentrée avec de très bonnes idées à
partager et les téléspectateurs peuvent
aussi retrouver un sur le lien qui s'est
affichée durant cet entretien le lien du
code skis notamment les dernières
publications et qui ont été établies par
ce conseil de développement de saint
quentin en yvelines dont vous êtes le
président merci blonde chance d'avoir
été avec no mercy notre mieux
[Musique]
le verdict de la cour criminelle de
versailles dans le procès pour viol
d'une policière des yvelines le pompier
de paris accusé dans cette affaire a été
condamné mercredi à douze ans de prison
l'homme de 39 ans avait avoué ses actes
au juge mardi après de longues semaines
où il les contestait les faits se sont
déroulés dans la nuit du 1er février au
2 février 2020 au domicile de la
fonctionnaire de police à guyancourt
l'individu avait été rapidement
interpellé par les forces de l'ordre
grâce aux indices laissés derrière lui
il a dix jours pour faire appel de cette
décision
autre condamnation celle de l'état qui
devra verser 1500 euros à la famille
d'un jeune homme pour fouilles illégales
à la prison pour mineurs de porcheville
en 2018 cet adolescent de 14 ans à
l'époque passe quinze jours de détention
sur place pendant son séjour trois
fouilles à nu lui seront imposées
une à son entrée et puis 2 par la suite
si le juge a reconnu que la première
fouille intégrale pouvait être justifiée
il a jugé en revanche les deux autres
illégal est la justice reconnaît le
préjudice moral dont était victime le
détenu a estimé que l'administration
pénitentiaire était coupable dans cette
affaire
une rencontre à présent dans ce journal
avec l'ina moreau qui est une jeune
plaisir oise atteintes de trisomie 21 à
14 ans elle est scolarisée au collège de
fontenay le fleury dans un collège de
fontenay le fleury elle mène au
quotidien de nombreuses batailles pour
réussir son projet professionnel
son portrait signé par célia 200 go à 14
ans lina fait ses devoirs tout seul une
tâche pas si simple pour cette jeune
adolescente atteint de trisomie 21 en
classe de 4è lille a un emploi du temps
bien chargé
elle doit composer entre sa classe
ordinaire et la classe ulis unité
localisée d'inclusion scolaire des
classes particulières avec très peu
d'élèves est en situation de handicap
s'est fait la malle et justin fait
lecture et c'est
écriture sa mère toujours derrière elle
en cas de besoin voit sa fille
progresser et prendre de l'autonomie en
sport j'ai fait j'ai fait frisbee et est
a pas oublié un mot devant j'ai fait les
frais ce bi ou du frisbee en plus c'est
mieux alors maternelle on lui donnait
même pas des ciseaux parce qu'on pensait
qu'elle savait pas des coupes des coupes
et alors qu'elle savait le faire en fait
cesser ces voix là c'est compliqué parce
que les personnes ne croient pas
forcément en elle parce qu'il ya une
trisomie 21 et qu'ils connaissent pas
forcément
il n'a su aussi des courants sec pas des
cours d'enseignement professionnel
adapté qui lui permettent de développer
son projet professionnel
car à 14 ans lina sait déjà ce qu'elle
veut faire que lainière dcp tarte aux
pommes étaient pda et c'est eux qui ça
lui plaît et du coup ça devient un
projet et puis et puis là elle vraiment
pris à son compte puisqu'elle va ouvrir
un restaurant
elle prépare des cartes de restaurants
donc c'est quelque chose qui lui tient à
coeur dans son collège à fontenay le
fleury l'enseignante ulysse en charge de
li na lui fournit des apprentissages
ciblé deux niveaux ce2 et plus encore
elle lui donne des exercices en lien
avec son projet professionnel pour
travailler la durée je m'appuie sur la
cuisson cuisine travail et la monnaie
sur peut être sur une des achats
d'ingrédients il n'a est arrivé il ya
trois ans dans ce collège
elle est suivie par là même enseignante
pour créer un lien de confiance les
besoins de li na c'est d'abord un
accueil en salle de dispositifs
individualisé vers d'autres vont arriver
ont posé leurs sacs et hop
li na c'est vrai qu'elle a besoin ce
soit avec la msa show avec moi bon d'un
bonjour individuel
ensuite tout ce qui est le langage lui
permettre de faire évoluer son lexique
les mollets les d'exprimer ses émotions
li na s'est rapidement fait des amis au
sein de ce dispositif ulis lina elle a
beaucoup apportés au dispositif
c'est une personnalité vraiment et j'ai
beaucoup appris moi en tant que
professionnel j'ai appris beaucoup de 2
li na en fin de troisième la collégienne
devra passer un diplôme le certificat de
formation générale
présentation d'un dossier sur un centre
d'intérêt ou un stage à l'oral pour
pouvoir ensuite rentré dans une ulis au
lycée elle pourra continuer son
apprentissage de la cuisine et décrocher
d'ici là un diplôme dans la restauration
culture la deuxième édition des menus
plaisirs d'été et lancer un projet
initié l'année dernière par le centre de
musique baroque de versailles
particularité cette année en plus de la
cité royale le spectacle s'exporte hors
les murs à maurepas et à la verrière une
manière d'aller à la rencontre du public
le reportage de justin brasier
menus plaisirs d'été un événement à
l'initiative du centre de musique
baroque de versailles
objectif faire découvrir le panel d'art
que représente la musique baroque
escrime chant danse théâtre une dizaine
d'artistes participent au projet quand
on crée un spectacle et un opéra
derrière il ya la machinerie donc il ya
des décors il ya des costumes
il ya des danseurs il ya des comédiens
chanteurs il ya des musiciens vous
faites c'est pour montrer que c'est pas
uniquement la musique et que derrière il
ya vraiment tout un tas de métiers et de
et d'artistes qui permettent de faire ce
spectacle
[Musique]
un spectacle humoristique et
participatif objectif faire découvrir et
vente accessible la musique baroque
pour nous c'est important de deux de
faire des petites choses participatifs
comme ça et de prouver en fait que par
le rire met à rire élégant à rire
baroque qui est qui et le rire du grand
molière le molière clics et sans doute
le celui qui nous fait le plus rire
encore de montrer qu'on peut participer
et que véritablement tout toutes les
générations peuvent accéder à ce
répertoire
d'autres représentations auront lieu à
versailles particularité le spectacle
sera complétée par des ateliers décor
champs ou encore costumes l'idée rentrer
dans les coulisses d'un spectacle
baroque les gens découvrent les ateliers
et ensuite à l'issue de ces ateliers là
il découvre le spectacle donc ils ont vu
un petit peu les différents acteurs qui
aura ensuite dans le spectacle après
deux jours à maurepas les menus plaisirs
d'été continue à la verrière pour un
spectacle en plein air et du 10 au 14
juillet au centre de musique baroque des
baffles et puis on referme ce journal
sur la route du mont saint michel avait
le ceni permet de rejoindre le lieu
depuis l'île de france grasset grâce à
450 km de pistes balisées
dans le cadre de l'opération mais à vélo
une délégation d'élus et d'associations
organisant un voyage de cinq jours pour
promouvoir le vélo et dans toutes ses
dimensions célia gars de son voyage
juillet de prix gens en ont profités
elles se sont mises en selle pour un
tronçon de 8 km en vallée de chevreuse
regardez
[Musique]
à
nous sommes au plein coeur de la vallée
de chevreuse à la maison de
l'écomobilité à saint rémy les chevreuse
c'est ici que l'on peut emprunter la
vélo ceni un itinéraire cyclable de 450
kilomètres qui relie le mont saint
michel à notre dame de paris
nous allons tester pour vous un tronçon
de huit kilomètres c'est parti avec moi
à la délégation de la vélo ceni quelques
élus et des représentants du club des
villes et territoires cyclables
ils vont parcourir l'avait losséni en
entier pour promouvoir cet itinéraire
vélo pour ce tronçon nous partons de
saint rémy les chevreuse direction
choisel est à peine 200 mètres parcourus
nous empruntons une piste cyclable c'est
plutôt agréable ne pas croiser deux
voitures
[Musique]
voilà ça fait 3 km que je roule ici on
peut voir de nombreux paysages donc
derrière moi le château de la madeleine
à chevreuse notre périple se poursuit
sur l'itinéraire de la vélo ceni nous
alternons entre pistes et bandes
cyclables on a fait quasiment la moitié
4 km 4 km 5
il ya des petits dénivelés des fois mais
avec le vélo électrique fait tous deux
embarquent arrivé à choisel l'occasion
de faire une halte à l'auberge des trois
hameaux et de discuter avec une
représentante de la ville au sénat on
april trajet de la vélo sony pour
organiser un voyage de cinq jours
aujourd'hui c'est notre deuxième journée
et on met en valeur en fait plein
d'initiatives vélo dont l'avait losséni
en filigrane on reprend le vélo
changement de vitesse quelques côte à
monter pour arriver à la ferté un hameau
de choisel devant nous des maisons de
pierre caractéristiques de ce village
quelques kilomètres encore et au loin
notre destination
le château de breteuil voilà j'ai fini
moi mon parcours des 8 km je me suis
arrêté au château de breteuil que vous
pouvez voir derrière moi sinon vous
pouvez continuer direction rambouillet
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]